you brought up quotas before of course
uh quotas which is like getting um a job
because of your gender or your race I
wrote them up for one no but I'm saying
you seemed like you said it was a good
thing you think it's a good thing I
think so don't you think it's kind of a
slap in the face because it's saying
that you can't do it yourself no not
really the reason why I think quotas are
I think but quote is a racist and sex
but but it is but the reason why I I'm
I'm a bit like I'm kind of going on the
whole thing of use races your superpower
I don't really care about why you're
doing it as long as I'm there and I can
make something good out of it then great
I'll go there and I'll turn it it's an
opportunity so if I if somebody now was
saying to me okay because you'll mix
racing you've got curly hair we want you
to present this show prime time TV bass
because you've got curly happy like yeah
no stress like let me do it let's see
how I'm gonna do I'm gonna get famous
I'm gonna make money I can open up the
business I can Empower through that
opportunity that came from a bad reason